[Music]
this is
ask Gary B
[Music]
everybody this is gary vay-ner-chuk and
this episode 151 of the askgaryvee show
I'm in a good mood India because this is
a very special episode this is a 360
askgaryvee you know everybody's gonna be
able to pay attention to answers lack of
athleticism which is probably probably
the most exciting part of the show but
we're out we're trying something new
here obviously you're you're recognizing
something different in your Facebook and
YouTube environments click around the
future is very much here I'm excited to
use some of vaynermedia x' brightness
and best for questions and and that's
that I think we've been off height we've
been on hiatus a little bit yeah one was
it was last show like d-roc it was last
show last week right anyway nonetheless
obviously we have a new video out which
I'm excited about overnight success so
that's important let's link that up and
and India I think it is time to get into
the show the 360 show let's do it Dan
what up hey my question is about
Facebook and how they recently started
their own creative in-house agency yep
what do you think about that how that
can affect the work we do and how do we
remain the experts on social when more
and more platforms are doing work
in-house platforms have done in-house
from the get I mean this is this is a
they're never gonna replace agencies and
and by the way if they do cool then
we'll adjust and we'll start selling
popcorn here at vaynermedia or something
I mean the reality is that there there's
there's too much danger for Facebook to
start doing that because the agencies
are gonna push back against that and
then start recommending other things I
think what they're doing is they're
trying to show best of class work things
that they believe in they're pissed off
at agencies for not doing Facebook stuff
trying to do TV stuff and there and
things of that nature
so I think they're looking at for it to
be a North Star they're looking to find
other agencies to follow that lead but
you know all of them snapchat Twitter
Pinterest Facebook it's where they all
got some love
this to me it's something I've never
worried about or other agencies I think
she'd really worry about mainly because
one if they're good enough and that
brings the most value to the customers
then that's what the market should be
and then all of you will work at
Facebook that's the way it should be but
- I don't think it's in their vested
interest as a platform to get into
client service business I think it's a
very my tiny dot in the ecosystem to try
to to try to move the creative in a
direction that I think is meaningful for
their platform and it's a good way to
spark you know look you're asking the
question so it's a good way to spark the
market for me I be fault in living in
that environment that you have to make
that content and so I'm not scared and
good for them and whatever Congrats your
egos thank you gotta leave of course oh
it's okay go Birds oh you got a mic real
professional here on three go Bercy
askgaryvee I'm not sure I'm comfortable
with that let's go over to Sasha
hey Sasha hi I've seen this extra
commercial trending everywhere extra
commercial commercial yes how do you
first see cinematic commercials within a
social space yeah I think that I think
the reason the extra commercial is doing
well is cuz it's a good piece of content
it's a beautiful love story played out
the brand is integrated smartly and not
forced and I think Facebook is the
environment to produce video for and
that's why we're seeing it do well
there's been great love stories executed
on television but if that ran on TV as I
go and I don't how do you know how long
it is to the night I don't know
totally seconds wrong as this they catch
it they did it touring you know the you
know the Superbowl or during the MTV
Awards and blocked off the time and ran
it it would be like oh that was nice it
wouldn't be like this cuz people are
sharing it basing it on this is the kind
of work I want to be doing at Vayner
this is the kind of work that I think
people are gonna be forced into in a
world where people don't want to watch
pre-rolls or commercials brands are
gonna have to find ways to actually make
great stories and actually integrate
their brand where it's not forced like
it's not like this is our show and this
is like a bottle company manner like I'm
just answering you know it's actually
part of its yeah I think it's an
absolute preview to where things are
going
things like this on youtube I think the
power of Facebook is the targeting and
the share ability that is extreme so I'm
excited about it yeah good question
thank you alright India bends hair is
getting long been not as long as yours
India learning and Ben can you stand up
there's a huge wet stain on your pants
yes Bill Cosby all right just let sloppy
just want anything just wanted the
vaynernation to know that yeah yes sir
question twitter twitter moment jesus
christ calm down guys now that twitter
moments is a week since launch exactly
one week after your initial thoughts and
do you think this is their attempt to
take on snapchat live stories i think
it's an absolute snapchat you know kind
of reaction though i have a feeling they
were working on it before which i think
is the problem in itself at twitter i
think last five years they've been slow
to innovate so whether it is a reaction
to what's working for snapchat or it's
always been in place they're both bad
answers I don't think it's some great
unbelievable thing I don't know I don't
know how much you've looked at moments I
just perfect while you're all on the
show support I don't I don't feel like
the moment stuff has been that
compelling of content which I think
scares me like yeah like I don't think
if you're if you're if you're not
compelled to watch it it doesn't matter
where it is in the UI or to UX the
content has to be right it feels a
little slap to get it feels like a slap
together random skew of like different
videos and pictures around a theme with
weak editorial curation at this point I
think if they can get that down it's
like being a great programmer right like
NBC wins when their lineup is the best
and you know in the 80s and 90s and I
think what what Twitter needs for that
to be successful if somebody really
knows how to curate content at that
level for me it hasn't hit the mark and
I've gone in there a lot already
I think the UI in the app is very
important it's it's work that's made me
go in there quite a bit but I haven't
been compelled by the content and the
thought of brands integrating in there
in the same way that I don't think
snapchats right move is least 15 or 10
second video ads I think that's gonna be
the more interesting part which is back
to the last question that Sasha just
asked you know a 10 second video that
just like eat extra gum is not as
interesting as what we saw there I think
it's gonna be their problem because
don't forget they have to build a
business around this so so far I'm not
super excited about it what about you I
think they need to add periscope support
I think that make it a lot more
compelling why cuz you're gonna be going
through a moment story and then you'll
see something live and that will
captivate you just yeah because I think
the problem with periscope is most
people suck at doing live video yeah but
I like the behind-the-scenes intimate
sort of brauneis of periscope so it
works out nicely that that content lasts
for 24 hours said of the moments I think
the timing works as well
I didn't sure they're debating that
question exam cleaner pants all right
who's next
Minnie Minnie how are you good how are
you green I like that yeah army service
so my question is just circling around
our culture and your growth yes
year after year and I've been here for a
year and just seeing our culture grow
twice in its size yep any impacts or
learnings that you've that you've taken
away that I have just shaped how we're
looking forward and how we're staffing
our business how we're maintaining our
culture I think the biggest thing I
learned over the last 18 months says
we've had a lot of growth is that um is
that if the intent is right and look at
you being the head of HR you have such a
view that so many other people don't
which is you get the see in the
closed-door meetings with me the
consistent Northstar of yeah I don't
know you've had HR jobs before like I
feel like a lot more people make a lot
more business decisions and the money is
a big variable and that's not give this
person any more time or let's fire this
person or let's promote this person
money I think you've sniffed out is so
not a variable in those decisions I
think it I think what's happened in the
last year to answer a question directly
I think even more confident than ever
that if your intent is right and you're
committed to that intent at the top
right that you can scale that whether
it's 20 people I mean look there's a ton
of people watching right now that works
in offices of 27 people and their
culture suck [ __ ] the amount of people
here that have worked at places that had
29 people I just met somebody the other
day and we're like it was like I just
came from another agency and our culture
was so bad
it's 16 people so I don't think the
number of employees is the variable of a
culture you know I think it's cliche and
accepted that when you grow you can lose
it my belief because I'm in a lot of
startups that have grown very big is
that what happens is CEO or the founders
take their eye off of the culture and
they start looking for the exit right
and when all of a sudden if you're
looking to sell to Google or Facebook or
or to another agency you don't care
about the people you care about the exit
right and then the culture hurts so how
do you define culture then I think it's
the collective feeling of everybody it
to me culture is a backwards thing of
like just do the people here actually
want to come to work and like actually
liked it and it's and it's not a chore
or it's not super stressful to me it's
how each individual feels that adds up
to one collective feeling awesome Thanks
India now last one yeah
Steve so my question is you're always
super busy always looking to take on
more how do you do it all let's let this
guy answer that Steve that was a pretty
good question but a really simple answer
to the question which is it just comes
down to time I mean at the end of the
day Steve because you've worked at
vaynermedia for 40 years I know that you
work oh I don't know
seven eight nine hours I work 18 so just
the volume of hours allows me to do a
lot more Steve think of it this way I'm
probably living twice the life that you
are and so like what it comes down to is
there's just a lot more hours of
execution and then also recognizing how
few things actually matter right so one
of things as you know as a veiner
employee we had a company-wide meeting
once talking about let's cut meetings in
half all those our meetings can be 30
all those 30 meetings can be 15 and so
at the end of the day I think the
biggest thing that people understand is
they waste time on dumb [ __ ] and so if
you have six minute meetings if you have
a two-minute call when it's scheduled
for 15
and when you actually work 18 hours a
day you can just fit in a lot more stuff
I think it comes down to ultimately
intent how much do you want to
accomplish what do you want to get done
and for me that's a lot of professional
stuff and in those massive amounts of
hours if I maximize the width 18 hours
versus nine and if I fit 97 things in
because you really only need seven
minutes not 15 or 30 the amount of
lallygagging that goes on by 99% of the
market in meetings or the things they're
supposed to do is extraordinary and so
keeping it tight and creating a lot of
volume is how I execute pretty special
show in the episode 151 pretty excited
about it the future is very much here
clearly and I hope you enjoyed it we
enjoyed making it you keep asking
questions I'll keep answering them